being is not speculative trying to do
that management in terms note how the 40
minutes right and I got to go release
interpretation of where it is located a
book world are and also to try to see
indications motivator internet Iranian
certainly hundred a 97 on the impact
this has on the region you really go
where they also for our understanding of
total sexual violence time I know I
again succeeded in a communal a computer
again as I got started but wrong so I
can start by pointing our and I got the
other big important ism and it's not
quite only little bit of a place of
understanding the cool going back to
these that were there in the exit
interview talent lovely that we use done
and then in the final part of our box I
will talk to these immigrants that this
has our way forgotten and great how to
coach me through what all these issues
of the all to be okay with all the
context our international context in
terms of Education which
Stan now it seems to me that we all are
we at point of a transformation in his
radical terms of use of the code and the
power this morning really reminded me of
that very powerful and it's not the end
of controversy but its beginning a very
new kinds of controversies it nothing it
seems to me is more than at the moment
in his robe rookies develop revival that
rebuilding his group of usual I want to
personalize this indignity through
graphical terms but I mean much Oh book
was written up to 10 15 years ago
multiple teams now in terms of the
general debate to be very much decide
where the framework for discussions now
is the question then seems to be that we
are moving your club standard are to
both new concepts and you are frames of
reference there is a diagnostic reason
because in terms of the division titles
of those seem to break to diamond as we
know this will definitely on both side
of those three runs a long time in a
second ah but this is a debate that is
inspired give those notch more by other
disciplines have such history into
Social Sciences nobody's going to
poverty decent on my on my side and
historical facility it's inspired by an
attempt to take seriously pointings that
are taking place outside guardian of the
states of rhythm
is very important a ck that's inputs of
use one on both sides of the void the
divider that works but I said so
interdisciplinarity international
approaches until to debate have become
much more important episode 13 of you
should be very happy about now what are
the directors haven't even stepped out
to me and which will critically inform
by hope much of the debate that we're
going to have for the next couple days
on the gold or in the Mediterranean but
you're not about lions are those short
form this morning what is that the Coco
was primarily a lot exclusive a clash
between capitalism and communism in the
global north with Germany at its core
that would inform the good work that
were substantiated Cold War that was a
definition of food to eat the hot now
you come to this conclusion from Deming
influence or converse you're preferring
to happens book which I haven't read yet
this this morning ah and there was over
by to buy buy buy buy all those karate
pokemon contests are different assays
the realist approach and will journals
on presumably us in that book based on
is this other one it is not this is not
about politics are some children between
academics is opposed
you know what I simpler in sections of
the stomach or the Cold War was fought
and vagina the one that I hear this is
anyone r which we understands the Google
as a full of continuous column you
control for example based on concepts of
development as much as gonna sleep our
time diplomacy but with the most
attractive solution always then threaten
or intervention on a global scale from
the avocado on driven by the United
States the Soviet Union has an extended
pain we provoke this petite little
adults officer also that you define week
11 not everything was new key which is
causing more but I suppose I mean in
terms of the new writing notes and is go
interesting you write heaters and I
think we could be much more than that
in five of the day between these two
delegates and no this has been able to
do with how approval was written around
up to 10 15 years of certainty ilysm in
terms of approaching now I think one of
the key issues are allocated in homes
will be discussed later on it's in
curious things so did to me during the
Cold War was united states united states
had a road with a lot of the convo that
was not what significant certainly south
of the Soviet Union hahaha what happened
the Soviet so it was that he became the
other superpower no in a gradual process
which I think we still do not entirely
understand you see similar thoughts of
intervention of similar stress to one
specific development and certainly from
the nineteen sixties or and yes as
someone said this morning but whiteley
gets you know so I think in the same
direction decided to locate much more of
the significance it's also understanding
in the data portal
do that doesn't origin or it was it has
to do with this development now I've
spent it all the time recently are
working on companies as we get a very
easy to do winterville so it's so like
that refreshing to return to these
controversies particularly in the
context of this of this conference at
the Deaconess hope to look at
Mediterranean are important all of the
deserts of the early approaches to how
we think about the coast of because it
very nice asian as was pointed out very
clearly this morning I don't need to
return to that is different as is the
historical trajectory certainly compared
to the north of Europe or the Atlantic
world or whatever so it I also think it
isn't the important spoil us maybe said
earlier most of the work that I thought
it is equal to do Widdecombe that you
will have approached you change with
regard to the essentialists for the some
people important to conceptual thing
more crystal in
in terms of inaudible conceptual
approach to D to record is to be able to
agree with evidence was certainly wasn't
everything that have a little scary
material that would be honest you know
yeah nothing we're going to snuggle that
there will be order and rayon regionals
you need to me the Mediterranean his
site and exit exam on how dangerous the
dangerous it is to superimpose a general
westernized framework one more the
witness must be very very weak so Mikey
foils are in the presentation today is
that a cool cool framework as in other
students within equal these two are
directing doesn't really work well for
the verge of its rating which issues as
legalization state construction
including Unity's of the nation this
point and at least the challenge of
transactions are limit the use of an old
road horrible to understanding its
government break but that's not the same
thing as saying that the coop will go
figure I also want the only thing
out here and against tommy was very much
driven by home or concerns Margaret is
that a when does Tim employ you know the
movement of the civic arts boxing
ability to locate the Soviet Union
what was going on is well taken in
diplomatic amid reasons this cricket is
a developer services if you can get it
in terms of planning went under
construction then certainly the Soviets
are they're always in all ways than one
so there is over significant orbital
between issues that is no darkness the
example might or what happened in the
Mediterranean during this period and
many of the Cold War disposes of the
database at the same time now let me try
to look at some of the reasons why do I
by the overall from another perspective
is approaching to be deeply problematic
with regards in Mediterranean and
understand the long-term users of mobile
things that are there if one clearly is
historical continuity of continuous
let's go back much longer than the home
itself manatees have to do with the
process of colonization and evil
and what was editing it was refused to
say this morning that the of colonial
control in Middle East wasn't the 19th
century was devoted 20s and they got it
exactly right this is a clear view isn't
in Game of imperial expansion not these
in terms of my ears and on your knees
into into the street fighting curious
people to pull it up works would be nice
the region more easily for the early
20th century through political granny
granny other here and there for the
debate about the significance of
colonial control and and I belong in
resistance carry over into the groove of
the integrated innovativeness other
places and you know wonderful literature
is allergic only are in terms of
understanding how these they come return
some of that a problem you work on on a
daily basis points very caring in that
direction then secondly in terms of
difficulties with using our paradigms
for the region nor the interactions
within the region and we need immediate
nails that sometimes go in directions
that not the measles boy who rang it
works great until he agrees
we need the same ministry Alliance for
functional to code no work that is no
one the right senses would say that
relationship between these two states
was created by the members of the same
with us it was a dangerous morning in
terms of how it was how it was mediated
how the development that one diminutive
related indicator of the increase
constituted not not excite was not what
happened within a cold war well it was
coming out of an undetermined amount of
radar or the Ottoman Empire these
various lat now finally and it's an ugly
transition from that's appropriate this
morning there is the role of religious
identities and how they affect the model
is people opportunities now this is
suppose a remarkably complex nominally
links to my own your own alcohol the
challenge of transnational transnational
is community yoga Detroit always rather
develop or interior visiting up there
hope for relief this is you mean that
the development of religious event on
boat maybe radiations deep into the
Amazon ah isn't I answered when you in
understanding the transition from the
early 20th century should be good
forever in fact that little Islamist
ilysm was very much food as I could
welcome student of that against it it is
something that mr. Hoover looked in
general Fergus prograf even all to be no
to certainly is ready to lose your
balance even less extreme and that is
the transformation of Christie democracy
on the node and scores for penetrating
and what that had to do with a
development or I fool or put a jason m
CQ eighteen states of justice or super
speck in the post at the end of as
opposed to what was going on now that's
another dog thing connection instance
you can see some infants for a photo but
it's also going over the broader sense
of sod all these issues you have all
dimensions student but it is not
original you it was the konbu that
create and if you are you know
to say if this book is called wall all
the other things are not hopeful at
least in those cook shillings a business
or asylum by and concern and run the
risk of an approach which it'll
overnight I turned out to be unethical
in understanding the book was called
when he sent me his not released during
the day we be looking at was fueled
volatile for the committee's public they
are is very comfy but not created by now
that you may already have gathered the
Mediterranean and I'll interest in the
zone Devin interested is emerging very
poor from Eurocentric conceptions mostly
based on identities another daughter
hope it includes Timothy's include South
Africa even includes two atomic states
that are not technically in the train
portugal abroad which are all very
significant reports the technical also
not common interest in hitting and
playing tonight one of the reasons why
those two countries are the cheaply
improve it does well at very
complimentary of the links that exist
between them and iron ii we immigration
or cocoa complex during our conservatism
very versatile by the collapse of the 47
and row that is hard not just oh not at
all at work musa getting in there but
for the global
likewise mirakkel are prone condo in the
nineteen sixties how to Bosnia sometimes
or patron Sony's all american indian
controls very ill during on explode so
he's been on we ended the train birthday
that I want earlier II history of the
20th century Mediterranean as i said in
it is very much a history of bermuda
sloop an equally safe in the processes
losses up to today is about the story
about going to distribute of the world
is mourning about british and french
control that the break double
penetration and it's also is relatively
stable dose may be equal to note it is
that you me and they come up to the game
suffered doers consequence of some of
its offensive thing he theories which
also i broke the sense which i think we
need to take into consideration in
understanding the historical processes
that we looking at with regard members
not sure will happen in a twenty century
in demonstrating zone develop outs of
the collapse of the opener without
understanding links that go from that it
was way off to the US dolls in place
we're missing a very significant part of
the teachers of I mean someone said and
Tony the green with it that no stalking
to think about the us-soviet prompting
the Cold War 3917 your clothes make
sense when a clearly you have dissolved
if you want to holla you register with
the antagonistic forces of parental
brain works it's likewise intimated
ready you have to stop the collapse of
the Ottoman Empire in order to
understand not sure what happened people
God how there is a of soda phone and it
did the implications of the COBOL are
for them and that participated
disruptions but it also created new
things tipo mediums links to you beloved
during the height of the Google
crucially important for instance
procreation of the non-aligned movement
are linked in my lead to how NASA
franquito tend to think in very similar
terms about concept of nation very much
because of the year ottoman
it's old but it was more pointed out the
Detroiters make that a number of people
do fight in terms of creating
instructions to the fact that the new
literacy was away had its origins now
clearly the northern coast MIT was
defined by these processes of
colonialism and people as they are both
will also serve a full in the shadow of
the Algerian war which remind you
created of America else causes
difficulties with accepting some aspects
for American digital begin you the story
of credit resistance against the market
the general is it that sense Massimo
that is open made made out to be an
acceptable concepts are not little but
their own and these lipids beginning
concentrated form the needs to continue
to fight a woman is very important in
unison in Italy great eras you give me
think you can speak of an internal
colonization and equalization in
relationship between the North and the
South that parallel not sure what was
going on on the southern coast of austin
and thready and this is it was something
that was deserves this morning had very
significant impressed impacts on our
record or receiving the hukou system was
the same again in itself also on coop
are an abundance of coming over to
evolve of sonic stealing society its
impact of the artists railing conflict
on the louisville training battalions
further and you can also it with very
well about it's an issue of resources
those are forms for the greeting it
becomes attention overcoming the
problems that we doesn't always work of
the holy mountain cities greatly greatly
and Crofts and unstable and that's what
we can further our papers on that you in
these mountains
ok let them end up by just doing a few
drinks with either processes that i have
discussed and what I improved through
your on the global concentration is very
real on what I want to consider when I
was licking its compost states within
the Mediterranean seven that's real
Yugoslavia Egypt and endearing and I'll
explain why he seemed to me to be the
central for those things this is obvious
her sexual predator wasn't getting get
the rest of my story activity and
they're all truly evil in order to
understand these kinds of Nixon
Yugoslavia was created very much as I
Cold War experiments in its socialist
for and he came to be defined but if I
computer position of his heart between
east and west from today announced to
all this because i was appointed to all
our concern is exactly attack the cold
war work on things were in for book kept
it was dogging together but it was also
interesting to hear what scholars who
concluded it was low gear in here have
to say about this what privately began
to hear it above and much of a saturday
wait the link that i mentioned do it
alone
kido sanity degeneration of public
appearances definition or what people
stop nation that fuels sex within a
favor that linked it to the
Mediterranean linked it to new
tendencies who's setting up
post-colonial states that have it's over
a million attractive and I should be
outside the framework so he was lonely
as a group or state for it is something
that's become increasingly important to
me as I literally right again own
particle those most don't know is
particularly during the latter
externally miss nettle tea but the word
that's other natives are all of these
for me it was known that all these now
seems to me to be very very this so he
has a bicycle state television verging
on a concept of national entity that is
created in seven I was in foreign policy
from the significance of this was
no Patrick was more activity so in
trying to do various post colonial
regimes of all the Mediterranean Sea
Islands and the role of users in Nigeria
and in Egypt world is one of the things
and people seriously marketers
understanding now Egypt be very focused
but it doesn't relate this one in terms
of concepts or great the idea of a new
widget relations on the boat or can
allocate is revolution the creation for
I hope of the load that is socialist
oriented also based to verify extend for
the experiences in the Soviet Union but
in it elsewhere Plus that it was too
late the game is something that is
menacing the great is a different
learning who the future of both the
would read you in how the other agencies
itself Egypt of those each character
which industry
go to them and that is today and
wondered many of us we're here so each
changes that makes in Egypt and into
early 1970s of two time zones were there
for even more evil some people think you
people from the dad wouldn't talk about
it does come to revolution after some
extent besides tentacles because even
only for about if of course what did you
think that was created between Egyptian
state and this is the world properties i
think in terms of every decision will be
dealing with a good move in the in the
Mediterranean Egypt's change oh Clark
into his relatives from brent oil also
giving you much more than just military
supplies and who go to a close alliance
between instead those who have created
the regime hoping out BRC again but it
was a period that will be connected to
what happened given on 27 so does it fun
to go into that now in its core is
starting that they are now getting on
the nineteen seventies perhaps and II as
you coconut oil take a motivation and
forth of the Mediterranean as the day 30
days notice 70 know it has perhaps he
will you vote to donate either in Arkham
and that what you're doing which some
people have referred to as the table
state make
is good hentai decides that there is no
better computer paralyzing human it's
raining home bottoms notice now that
he's inviting all these home people's
will go to book the league's well I
material because the Cold War Horse
imperiousness is not primarily about the
policy and thats cool this is not a word
of course the body goes diplomatic
revolution that basic terms of how
uranium US bases filled with its for a
policy in the priests name hearing what
was significant for our future a Negroni
instruction it means significance was in
sort of the low and it's of the
development plan and there is no better
example or significance of planning that
he lives audience doctor then Egeria
from the midnight diseases what we often
forget today is that this particular
girion form of them seem to be immensely
successful and happiness
me that is all the further with your
father's name we were trying to take
cost of the same game now invite you in
a canoe ilysm invite you that he really
is really d he stated in terms of
connecting the hook with only three it's
also qualitative about oneself on this
was because of your pose as well that by
the corner ended the state project broke
down in the significance in terms of
them for understanding how to prove will
pay it in terms of a person and very
little to do with the general various
concerns and of course discussions
concern about diplomacy milk reappears
and strategy or more visible in East
countries than animals so we then on
that note he'll get where they are done
to get the dollar project me with
regards business in order to try to
understand the movie
you